ann and keo and vernon and peeta
are at the bottom two
there's actually been an error i'm
looking right now and we have
three couples so we need to clarify this
for one second
oh it's awkward on monday night's
episode of dancing with the stars
tyra banks accidentally revealed the
wrong couple in the bottom two
the bottom two couples are anne and keo
and monica and val
please come back please have monica come
back
let's rewind things were all fine and
dandy with three couples waiting to find
out their fate
anne heisch and keough and gleb
and vernon davis and peta that's when
tyra announced
this ann and keo and vernon and peta
are at the bottom two well that lasted
like a nanosecond before the 46 year old
tv personality revealed
there had been a mistake the bottom two
couples
are anne and keo and
monica and val
please come back please have monica come
back yeah
monica and val had already exited stage
left
because tyra had previously announced
that they were safe
i mean it was just a surreal moment it
was
like we went from zero to a hundred back
down to zero really fast
so you know i mean i we you know just
went back up there smile
like i said awkward there's been an
error in our control room that we're
making it happen
this is live tv right this is the
craziness of live tv
there were only a few minutes of the
show left so there wasn't time to
explain the flow
but tyra did apologize noting that her
cards were wrong before quickly asking
the judges to name the couple they
wanted to save
again we apologize for this this is live
tv and we're all human
okay it's time for the judge's verdict
the judges saved monica and val
sending anne and keough who were also in
jeopardy last week
home we're gonna hear it one more time
for
ann and keo we love you guys so much
okay
and then you guys go celebrate monica
and val
please note the look on val and monica's
faces as they walk
off the stage confused af
it was crazy it was shocking and to be
honest we still don't know
you know so this is an exclusive you're
getting this we
just came off the stage so um
i don't have the answer for you i guess
you know like
tyra said you know it's live tv um
what you see is what you get right after
the big on-air blunder
et spoke with the cast and they admitted
the whole thing was
totally wild i didn't know what to think
because i knew there was three couples
and then she said you guys are in the
bottom two with ann and keo and i'm like
that doesn't make sense like how does
that work lead needs to go away then
and then it just started to unravel yeah
i mean i knew right away something you
know
someone made a mistake i'm glad we were
able to sit here and
and move on to the next week but
everything was handled
in good manner what happened is one of
it's like television things
you know things like this happen
especially when it comes to
information coming from all over the
country voting calculating and there is
such a small amount of time
to get the people on the right order and
while this wasn't tyra's first hiccup as
the new host of the hit show
she's not letting the flubs get her down
after the season's second episode
she hit up tick tock to shut down the
haters
it wasn't perfect yeah i had a lot of
fun
but i messed up i said the wrong words
but the thing is i kept kept going
forgive yourself when you mess up
stand the heck up and keep going and
dancing with the star's judge
bruno tonioli totally has her back
you know she's she's doing it the way
she wants to do it you know he's like
he is people are there is you know
it's a bit tiring all the negativity and
and not even giving people a chance
you know although you know just let her
be who she is
and she does it her way we're having a
great time the viewing figures are
great you know we'll get on we are
giving we are trying to give
two hours of entertainment and fun to
the people
why don't you focus on that